[Music]
i call it the nature's number i'm
actually interested to find out that
whether
in nature there's this like number or
there's this like
equation that we can form and whether
this equation equals to like how we name
or how we see design
so then i was like sitting by the
roadside
and that's where i see trees i see trees
lined up together
i see trees that you know they are being
separated there's like a specific breed
of trees that have been like you know
distance so then it makes me question
like uh whether this distancing of the
plants um is there like a fixed rule or
is it by guard feelings yeah
my main objective wasn't to like first
glance you know what is it
just like numbers when you see a bunch
of numbers you don't want that so there
is a lot of
numbers yes there's a lot of numbers
and my last question is are these
numbers important because i give you
lots of numbers and gives you the
legislative altitude but
now we're gonna ask we don't want it we
need to look
yeah exactly but i feel like today uh we
pay so much attention to numbers
and time
yeah
it's all numbers and whether those
numbers are really important
it's for us to think about
so how do we make connection to like
this bunch of numbers to quite
understand or why you read off the chart
so it's more like how you draw this
connection between like you and this
project i think there's definitely this
beauty about design
if you mention the world without design
just like going into a jungle i think to
a certain extent i really understand yes
like any form of like human creation
is sort of designed
[Music]